I'm going to start with a true or false
question for the two of you uh true or
false you only agreed to do this movie
because you would be on stage with
Weezer uh false I did it for the
enormous
paycheck no uh false I am a fan of
Weezer and maybe I'm going to be the
only one that realized that's rivers in
the band um so what was it actually like
I'm not sure if you're a fan of the band
it's all of Weezer in the band no that's
what I mean like it's it's Weezer on
stage I was watching it yesterday and
I'm like wait that's Weezer you know um
so what was it actually like working
with those guys you know I was very
excited to work with them because I have
been such a huge Weezer fan for so long
uh what I didn't expect was how
just playful and committed and uh and
just all in they would be and they
really were like they just were so
present and ready to have a good time I
mean I there's versions of that where a
band could show up and just be like okay
where do you want me to stand like what
do you want me to do or whatever but
Weezer like they just were psyched and
it made it super
fun yeah I mean it was it was super sick
I mean that that band is is so legendary
and I mean my my mom was telling me a
lot how how she grew up on them and and
I would go back through my Spotify and
listen to a bunch of weer songs before
Weezer songs before they uh they came to
set that day and had to do my research
but it was it's definitely uh it's
definitely experience that I remember
for a while so you see the shooting
schedule what is the day you have
circled in terms of oh this is going to
be a pain in the ass day or this is
going to be an amazing day any day I was
working with Ed I would how much did he
pay you to say that come on wait was
that pain in the ass day or amazing yeah
no pain in the ass day circle circle I
was like God I have
to going to going to note that that's
going to be a terrible day yeah yeah I
understand again restraining
yeah so you also have a
okay uh anything with like the that was
stunt heavy with the car chases and the
the the telescope scenes with the the
the the the harnesses and the falls and
I love that stuff like I could do I
could do that all day so I was always
psyched to do that I would imagine with
one of these kinds of films uh the body
swap genre that they're actually you're
thinking before you step on set that
first day about how am I going to play
the other person you know um so talk a
little bit about how you both got ready
and I know you've been asked this but
did you guys talk did you try to copy
some mannerisms yeah uh a lot of it went
into I would say the the pre-production
of of the film was was kind of the most
important I feel like um because that's
where we really got the time to to learn
each other and and pick up on each
other's mannerisms and we did a lot of
did a lot of work with our movement
coach um as well so we can just really
get those those physicalities um as
realistic as possible can I give him the
real answer yeah so that's what we're
obligated to say but what really
happened is that we found a genie who
could actually switch our bodies and so
Brady and I switched bodies for like a
month and we didn't tell anybody so we
just we couldn't yeah and so we just
went through the world as each other and
we really dialed it in and that was like
a month before movie so we were like
ready to go I'm sure Netflix appreciated
it actually saves money you know listen
um I got to go I really do hope it's a
huge hit for you guys thank you again
for lifting the restraining order and uh
great meeting you and you know have have
fun with the speed dating thanks awesome
appreciate